you know that it's serious if i'm
emotional
things are heating up between kourtney
kardashian and travis barker
the reality star sent her new boo a cute
love note i love it
barker shared the sweet sentiment on his
instagram stories
it reads quote to lots of fun adventures
may we destroy each other completely
while fans may find the destroy line a
bit confusing
it appears to be an expression
understood between the couple
travis tweeted the exact line just days
before courtney's love note was
posted to his instagram stories et
learned last month that kardashian and
barker begin dating after years of
having a platonic friendship
a source tells e.t quote they've been
friends and family friends for a very
long time
but recently something sparked and that
relationship has turned romantic
just like living life and whatever
happens happens
the source goes on to say quote things
are super easy between them
because they know each other so well and
just click and get one another
yeah what is happening here while
courtney is moving on it seems like her
ex scott disick gives his full support
on her new relationship with travis
yeah it's great i mean i think we've
been through so much in so many things
a source revealed to et quote it's
always a bit of an adjustment when one
of them is dating someone new
but at the end of the day he obviously
wants courtney to be happy
and they're focused on co-parenting
together scott has also since moved on
to model amelia hamlin
and the two were recently spotted out in
miami with his kids for the first time
publicly
at the sugar factory et has learned that
the keeping up with the kardashian star
was seated with his three kids between
him and hamlin
who were seen acting upbeat laughing and
enjoying the sugar rush
a source disclosed that the couple is
having a blast together
saying quote they've been going out with
friends spending time together
and overall just having a really good
time they're still not super serious and
are just taking things day by day
and keeping things light and fun while
the source also revealed that courtney
is doing just fine
and doesn't quote have romantic feelings
towards scott anymore
the latest trailer for the final season
of keeping up with the kardashians
leaves fans wondering what the future
will hold after this confession from
scott
i'll marry you right now